cheese butter is the delicious gourmet
cheese melt that blends four indulgent
cheeses and seasoned butter i love this
stuff perfect on bread bagels sandwiches
veggies and more you'll get 15 off at
cheesebutter.com pacman the link is down
below
welcome everybody um so things in the
russian invasion of ukraine
have not gotten any better over the
weekend and i'm going to tell you what's
been taking place and talk about
what might be the most likely
path towards de-escalation given
the personalities involved particularly
the personality of vladimir putin and
given what we have seen so far but in
order to have the conversation about how
we might get out of this we have to
understand how escalated things have
gotten and how committed to some degree
degree vladimir putin is
about um uh pushing forward and
a major
sort of i hesitate to use the term red
line because red line has had so many
particular meanings in foreign policy
over the last 15 years in the united
states but
some kind of rubicon has been crossed
over the weekend
with the start of russian attacks
on ukrainian nuclear power plants
and the concerns over
an explosive disaster proverbially and
literally have now become a significant
part of the discussion as to what's
taking place there's an associated press
report
attack on ukrainian nuclear plant
triggers worldwide alarm and why would
it not
um news from kiev
russian troops friday seized the biggest
nuclear power plant in europe after a
middle of the night attack that set it
on fire and briefly raised worldwide
fears of a catastrophe in the most
chilling turn yet in moscow's invasion
of ukraine
firefighters put out the blaze no
radiation was released russian forces
pressed on with their weak old offensive
on multiple fronts although they did not
appear to gain significant ground in
fighting friday the number of refugees
fleeing the country eclipse 1.2 million
one of the realities that we have to
sort sort of uh accept at this point
is that
this
you know pyrrhic victory
maybe too far
but
the way in which ukraine is now reacting
to the attacks
if the invasion is ultimately going to
be successful for vladimir putin and of
course i hope that it's not and i i
still believe that there's a good
possibility that it's not
putin is going to succeed in taking some
extraordinarily lamb damaged territory
and what i mean by that is when you
consider the destruction to
infrastructure that the russian troops
seem totally willing to make when it
comes to nuclear power plants roads
important uh government buildings etc
and when you consider the refugee
exodus from the country uh and the
further damaging effect that that's
going to have if there aren't people to
take care of things then it's going to
get even worse
there is a putin who seems determined
to have a quote victory no matter how
disastrous the victory is in terms of
damage to russian troops in the russian
economy and to what he's trying to steal
ukraine
in and of itself and the nuclear power
plant is just sort of like the epitome
of that because consider the damage you
could do uh by by going after that
another report uh russian forces fire
rockets at building in kharkiv that
houses a nuclear reactor this is
extraordinarily dangerous stuff and i
know some will say well david it's not
that dangerous i mean these it's still
probably going to be fine yes when you
deliberately target these types of
facilities you're willing to accept
serious and significant destruction this
article reads ukraine's national
security service have claimed that
russian forces are firing rockets at a
physics institute in kharkiv
which contains nuclear material and a
reactor
footage shows the purportedly shows the
moment a missile hits the kharkiv
institute of physics and technology
which houses the reactor no immediate
reports of damage to the nuclear
materials inside so one very important
question now becomes
what is the off ramp if we
let's concede a situation
where putin is unable to take ukraine
successfully in a short period of time
ima given the size of the russian forces
um and the seeming determination of for
example joe biden not to send troops in
which i support to be clear given all of
that
it's not unlikely that if this did last
at the in at this scale months or longer
that at some point russia would quote
win ukraine in the sense of stealing it
but it's not coming easily and we're
going to talk about that more
and given that
what sort of circumstances would be the
most likely to get putin to say i'm i'm
going to back off now well the first and
the most important thing is putin will
back off
seemingly if he's dead or if he has some
face saving way of backing off given
that
an attempted assassination does not
appear to be the policy of any country
that's been asked about it so far and we
will get to that because there was a big
story on that over the weekend
how do you create an off-ramp for putin
where he can sort of save face
the best kind of average of everything
that we know going on would be
you have to make it as difficult as
possible
for russia to make progress while making
it as economically damaging as possible
does that have uh unintended
consequences of hurting the russian
people of course it does what what is
already happening what's already been
done in terms of sanctions
hurts russian people as well stories of
i mean just anecdotally even just
russians outside of the country unable
to to use debit cards i mean at the
micro level it's hurting russians and at
the macro level it's going to do
significant damage as well energy prices
all these different things but it seems
as though
what you
short of sort of sending troops in uh to
ukraine and and starting to fight a
ground war of sorts you need to continue
sending support to ukrainian troops and
what are at this point significantly
volunteers as well
allow them to slow the progress of
russian troops as much as possible
make it i mean it's crazy the terms
we're talking about we're talking about
lives here make it as deadly as possible
for putin to continue pushing hurt the
economy as much as possible and pressure
putin
to
get some kind of incentive to take an
off-ramp and then give him some way to
do it while saving face now what will
that mean does that mean you've got to
give them some land i don't know and
this is where
diplomacy would presumably take over but
that seems to be the path sort sort of
really waging a war in ukraine which
right now it's not really a war it's an
invasion
that ukrainians are doing what they can
to repel understand that this isn't
a war came up because of aggressive
behavior from both sides no russia
invaded ukraine that's what started this
there has to be some path
that will suit putin's personality and i
don't know what that is but this isn't
stopping putin uh
uh from from trying to knock out the
president of ukraine zalenski and that's
what i want to talk about next
last week i told you that ukrainian
president vladimir zelensky
survived an assassination attempt there
was this
unit of chechen special forces the
khadiravites and they had been
um they established a plot
to assassinate the ukrainian president
zielenski
and um we now have learned that there
have actually been three such plots
which the ukrainian president has
survived this is being reported by the
new zealand herald and many others
russia ukraine war and again it's really
russian invasion of ukraine president
vladimir zelinsky survives three
assassination attempts in the last week
the ukrainian president has reportedly
survived three assassination attempts in
the past week alone
the times in the uk reports that
mercenaries from the kremlin-backed
wagner group and chechen special forces
both attempted to kill the president in
the last week according to reports the
assassination attempts failed because of
subversive anti-war members within
russia's federal security service the
fsb which is the successor to the kgb
some elements of the fsb didn't want
this to succeed they didn't want
zolensky assassinated and they alerted
ukrainian officials fascinating the
ukraine secretary of national security
and defense has confirmed three foiled
assassination attempts
he told local media he received
information from double agents who do
not want to take part in this bloody war
according to reports news of one of the
assassination plans sparked the 36-hour
curfew keiv was under last week so
soldiers could sweep the streets for
russian saboteurs civilians were warned
they could be liquidated if they were
spotted outside during curfew as they
would be assumed to be the enemy
sources say the wagner group mercenaries
have been in ukraine since january and
are tracking zolensky and colleagues via
cell phones and then on march 1 this is
what i told you last week a chechens hit
squad also tried to kill zolensky but
failed as the fsb
also reported their movements you know
there's there's a couple of interesting
things to talk about here
um
in the last 10 days
putin says i have no ill intentions this
is a military operation and yet in the
last 10 days
zielinski has survived three
assassination attempts
russia has bombed at least one
kindergarten
at least one orphanage as well as at
least one if not two nuclear power
plants slash sites housing nuclear
reactors okay
so
the the framing
that we have heard from the apologists
for what putin is doing as a very
limited
military operation those can go
in the toilet the same place trump puts
his documents right um but in all
seriousness it's
impossible to even imagine what zolensky
and his family are going through right
now and the very interesting thing you
know later we're going to talk about
lindsey graham talking about
assassinating vladimir putin
but yet we've had actual assassination
attempts against zolensky i believe that
if putin were assassinated
that would cause a collapse to this
entire this entire invasion
but not the other way and what i mean by
that is as follows ukrainians actually
understand what's going on they
understand that putin has invaded they
understand what they're fighting for and
while zelensky is the leader
the movement to defend ukraine and
resist russian invasion would continue
even if zolensky were killed if zolensky
were killed they're still going to do
everything they're doing to repel russia
maybe even bolstered okay there
you that's what would happen if zolensky
were killed on the other hand
many russian troops and even some
russian generals don't seem to think
this is a particularly good idea the
invasion of ukraine
they don't even know what they're
fighting for we have incredible video
from a captured pow russian troop who
was like i don't know we we were told
all this stuff we got here it's not even
really true it's crazy
if putin did die the invasion would
almost immediately end whereas killing
zelensky won't actually uh have that
effect let me know your thoughts
um
find it find me on twitter at dpakman
we'll take a quick break
one of our sponsors today is cheese
butter giving you 15
off i love this stuff cheese butter is a
delicious gourmet cheese melt that
ingeniously blends
four indulgent cheeses and aromatically
seasoned butter
all the ingredients the cheese the
butter the seasonings are sourced for
the highest quality you can really taste
that this was made with fresh simple
high shelf ingredients nothing
artificial
cheese on bread right i mean come on and
butter on bread
why wouldn't i love cheese butter put it
on french bread sourdough bagels english
muffin jewish rye
pumpernickel
sandwiches grilled cheese burgers baked
potatoes mac and cheese broccoli veggies
cheese butter is a business that
supports the david pakman show support
them their product is really fantastic
it's been a secret recipe in their
family for 50 years
taste it for yourself to really
understand what it's about
i don't think you'll be sorry cheese
butter is giving my audience 15
off when you go to cheese
cheesebutter.com
pacman
so uh radical republican or maybe
confused republican senator lindsey
graham lindsey graham strikes me more as
confused than radical i guess although
every once in a while he will say
something pretty radical he suggested
assassinating vladimir putin and then
all hell broke loose and by the next day
there there was no more talk of
assassination instead he was talking
about arresting vladimir putin a much
more sober and modest suggestion but i
have to tell you
what lindsey graham said
is not dissimilar
to what is going on
in many intelligence
agencies back rooms it's just you can't
publicly say it i'm going to explain
what i mean so let's get to the first
clip this is lindsey graham uh in the
evening i think this was thursday night
where he said we need a plot we need
someone in there
who's going to kill putin the way there
was a plot to kill hitler how does this
end
somebody in russia
has to step up to the plate is there
brutus in russia is there more
successful colonel stoppenberg in the
russian military the only way this [ __ ]
ends my friend is for somebody in russia
to take this guy out you would be doing
your country a great service and the
world of great service right
that's that's pretty full on for for a
senator in the united states to say the
best path is assassinating putin okay so
what is he talking about well he's
talking about uh stauffenberg
full name would be klaus philip maria
justinian schenk graf von stauffenberg
this was a german army officer
who um i guess we would say executed a
failed attempt in july of 1944 to
assassinate adolf hitler at the
so-called wolf slayer so
lindsay is saying we need something
similar we need someone from inside
russia
to take out vladimir putin so this was
completely irresponsible to say
and obviously it's being considered i
mean le we let's not let's not play dumb
here guys
there is no doubt
that every serious intelligence agency
and i'm not defending them from doing it
i'm just telling you that it's obviously
going on
every serious intelligence agency is
giving all options to their leaders and
one option is could we and if so what
would it take
to assassinate vladimir putin or
similarly i mean the idea that lindsay's
talking about is someone from inside
russia
any serious intelligence agency
that has
moles double agents whatever within
russia would be saying do we have anyone
inside of russia
close enough to putin that they could
potentially assassinate putin i'm not
saying anyone is planning to do it
i'm not saying that it should be done
i'm saying when you are in a position of
providing options to leadership
you provide every option and almost
always in situations like this one of
the options is could we kill someone and
could we do it with enough plausible
deniability that it can never be traced
back to us
however it's not something a senator
should say it's very stupid it's
extraordinarily dumb for lindsey graham
to say it but to just write it off and
pretend these conversations aren't being
had would be extraordinarily naive now
by the next day lindsay had completely
backed off
obviously someone got to him and they
were like yeah that's you can't say that
you can't say that and lindsay instead
said well we should really be looking at
arresting putin mr ambassador you're
supporting a war criminal in putin
your country is engaged in war crimes in
front of the entire world you're bombing
innocent civilians using banned
munitions you have a record your country
does of dropping barrel bombs on people
in syria you've destroyed czechsnia by
massive war crimes you're committing war
crimes uh in the ukraine you need to
apologize to the world
for how putin has stolen your country
blind how they're dismembering a
neighboring democracy called the ukraine
how they're killing innocent men women
other than continuing to say
the ukraine lindsay's basically right
about his allegations as to what's going
on in children indiscriminate use of
force and violation of the geneva
convention you my friend are the one who
needs to apologize and when it comes to
putin he needs to go to jail okay so
toning it down very much from the
assassination talk to go to jail you
could liken this to
the previous night lindsay was drunk
texting and then the next day he sent an
email to smooth things smooth things
over okay and that's an analogy i'm not
saying literally he was drunk texting
the night before
so he's essentially right he was very
wrong to talk about the assassination
but let's let's be adults here obviously
countries the world over are saying
would we be able to pull off an
assassination and what would be the
risks and the rewards and the
implications and as i said earlier
three assassination attempts against
zolensky i don't believe that if you
kill zalensky you really change anything
about ukrainian resistance in fact i
think you might bolster it because they
would be so invigorated by what would be
the insane killing of their president i
do think on the other hand that uh
if you kill putin you you do in a sense
decapitate the russian movement the
russian invasion because so many people
in russia clearly don't even want to be
doing it so that's what's going on and
lindsay said the wrong thing quite
frankly
this is one of the strangest videos i
have seen in a long time in an absurd
absurd phone call the story almost
slipped through the weekend kind of
quietly but it's completely outrage
outrageous donald trump had a phone call
with professional golfer john daly now
you might say why well maybe they were
talking about golf actually they were
talking about foreign policy donald
trump was on the phone
with professional golfer john daly
and he talked about nuclear weapons
and claimed that he once threatened
putin with bombing moscow
that's the story it it it makes no sense
it's it's almost beyond belief like what
what why is trump on the phone with
daley why are they talking about foreign
policy it's all bizarre and of course if
it's true that trump threatened putin
with bombing moscow
that's a fascinating story too let's
take a listen to this this is trump on
speaker
speaking to john daly who increasingly
looks like glenn beck interestingly
enough and um
listen to what he had to say
you know
he was a friend of mine i got along
great
i said we're gonna hit moscow and he
sort of believed me like five percent
ten percent that's all you need he never
did it during my time john you know no
you're all talking about it no he's
years because he knew funny couldn't
it's funny how she didn't bother you
either
i like how he says by the way chi
yeah now she didn't bother me
that'll be next yeah you know that's
going to be next time one will be next
you won't have any computer chips
they'll blow them off the face of the
air you won't have it
now i i actually agree with trump there
there's a real possibility that china is
increasingly salivating over the idea of
doing something with taiwan given what's
going on in ukraine right now with
russia um but how wild is this trump
told putin he would hit moscow if
it but this this was previously unknown
in terms of our geopolitical relations
and foreign policy that trump had
threatened putin with bombing their
capital city but i mean
i i looked and there's no record of that
that i was able to find now
it's possible trump meant he told putin
he wanted to hit the moscow strip clubs
that it is possible that that's what
trump meant we don't want to rule it out
but i think he is talking about bombing
now the other someone wrote to me and
said david
is it possible trump thought he was
speaking
with john stewart from the daily show
instead of john daly like maybe that's
the explanation and as funny as that is
i don't think it really makes a
difference because this is still
something we we did not know donald
trump supposedly told putin but do we
believe this like trump even said i was
friends with putin i don't know i mean
is is that even really true and this
could be another one of these instances
of trump wanting to be the alpha in
front of the pro athlete it's all very
very strange but trump very casually
mentioning something to a golfer that if
true
it's an incredible story that that would
be incredible if that is a foreign
policy discussion that took place it's
also silly to talk about this with john
daly
because daley's an expert
in latin america not in russia okay
anyway um
that
now of course it might just all be a lie
who knows why is trump on the phone with
a golfer and saying these things how do
these phone calls get scheduled in the
first place
do you think it's a random call or what
what's the backstory it's bizarre and
one other note
some people are reacting as if trump
said
i threatened putin with nuking moscow
it's not at all clear from what trump
says that he's talking about nukes now
it's true
maybe he is i don't know i don't think
he's talking about nuking moscow he's
talking about bombing moscow
it's all crazy is is the point and why
trump is having these conversations with
pro golfers or former pro golfers i
genuinely don't know
but it is another reminder
that it's going to take years for us to
know the full scope of the absurdity
that was foreign policy under trump if
you're just listening today we'll have
this clip on our instagram which you can
find at david pakman show and by the way
real quick real quick i'm going to say
more about this tomorrow we are
launching a coaching initiative for
up-and-coming
podcasters youtubers and content
creators we are
accepting applications at
davidpakman.com
coaching if you are already a content
creator okay that's the now listen
carefully to that if you were already a
content creator with a youtube channel
podcast or whatever
you can apply for free coaching from me
at davidpakman.com coaching we're going
to be doing uh recorded
coaching sessions with a small curated
group of creators the goal being to grow
your platforms and your shows and your
content creation so you can apply at
davidpakman.com
coaching it's a very cool new thing i'm
super excited to do it sort of like a
giving back i'm going to help people
after i was helped um you can uh apply
at
davidpakman.comcoaching and i'll have
more information about that for you
tomorrow
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
so donald trump's former attorney
general william barr
is now coming out and saying all of
those election
lies trump was telling they were lies
they were bs he had these lawyers
working for him but the lawyers were a
quote clown show that's a quote from
william barr
and everybody now is saying here's a guy
willing to tell the truth about the guys
he wrote a book he wrote a book and now
he wants to sell the book and like
everybody else he kept the most
interesting stories for the end now
did he actually
object
enough
to what was going on with donald trump
while he was working for him to say no
more well
only at the absolute end remember
william barr didn't resign until
december 23rd or something like that of
2020
and he seemed to be wanting to get the
hell out of there before whatever was
going to happen on january 6th happened
but he went along with it all along he
was willing to work for trump and on and
on and on and we can't let these guys be
rehabilitated
but what william barr says is really
interesting
here is an interview that william barr
did with nbc nightly news host lester
holt where he says it was all bs and i
told him that all this stuff was blue
and
about election fraud
and uh
you know it was wrong to be shoveling it
out the way his team was
and he started asking me about
different theories and i had the answers
i was able to tell him this is wrong
because of this you're trying to set him
straight yes and and and you know he
listened
he
he was obviously getting very angry
about this i said okay well look i
understand you're upset with me
and i'm perfectly happy to tender my
resignation and then boom he slaps the
desk he slapped the desk and he said
accepted
accept it
and then boom he slapped it again accept
it
go home don't go back to your office go
home
you're done
so that is a firing folks now remember
that at the time
we were
when this when this happened when it was
announced william barr is leaving
we all understood
this this is a firing at this point in
all likelihood and indeed it was um and
uh it is just another one of these
examples where
some see this and say what what a great
guy what a hero william barr willing to
tell the truth he's willing to tell the
truth uh what is it 15 months later
because he's trying to sell a book would
have been useful to hear this stuff at
the time and uh there is another segment
of this interview
where he talks about the clown show of
lawyers that donald trump brought out
and it was quite a clown show
and
about election fraud
and
it was wrong to be shoveling it out the
way his team was
and then he also told trump what he
thought of his legal team
not a lot
i said the reason you are where you are
is because you wheeled out a clown show
of lawyers
a clown show yeah clown car or something
like that i said it's just a bunch of
clowns
who are you referring to
rudy giuliani's cracker jack legal team
and my lovers mars says the president
shot back listening so guys obviously
barr is right and it's funny to hear him
talk about those clown lawyers in these
terms but
he was complicit with so much of what
went on for so long he misstated what
was in the mueller report you know he's
not a good guy ways he said barr had
failed him that's when barr says he
offered up his resignation i said okay
well look i understand you're upset with
me
and i'm perfectly happy to
tender my resignation and then boom he
slaps the desk he slapped the desk and
he said accepted
accepted which we heard already boom he
slapped it again accept it
go home don't go back to your office go
home
you're done when we asked the former
president about this meeting he disputed
barr's account and told us he was the
one who demanded barr's resignation
either way barr handed in a resignation
either way it was a firing letter two
weeks later and has not spoken with
donald trump since
he does not want him to run for
president again
all right
so listen why is william barr doing this
now uh it's because he wrote a book and
he wants to sell a book and there's this
sort of rehabilitation tour
and maybe part of it is also distancing
from trump for future opportunities or
whatever but it's almost certainly just
to sell a book that's the that's the
theme they hold on to the juicy stuff or
their indignant and principled
statements until they have a book to
sell i think they mostly do tell the
truth william barr or whoever stephanie
grisham wrote one and now i don't even
remember all the people who have written
books it's just at a particular time for
a particular benefit they start telling
all of those stories now the other
aspect of this is
any opportunity that trump has to talk
about barr trump will almost certainly
throw bar under the bus so it's like why
hold back at this point anyway but
remember barr is not a good guy it's
like hey mitt romney said one thing that
makes sense but he's still a guy i don't
really agree with politically
all of the former trump people that were
are worse because they worked for trump
um
barr
lied to congress with regard to
important parts of the mueller report he
he lied in that letter that he put out
remember the letter
summarizing the mueller report which
wrongly said that it
cleared trump of obstruction which the
mueller report very clearly did not so
if you're actually interested in this
book i'd wait a few weeks it almost
certainly will show up in the 99 cent
area within a few weeks or a couple
months that's almost always the way it
happens with these political books i
will not be buying the book and what in
terms of the movement that barr is now
part of
i would be willing to concede that barr
seems to be exiting the worst of the
worst trumpian fringe sure he he resigns
slash was fired he calls out bs when he
sees it okay fine
but he's taking a step back
to the pence mcconnell republican party
which is almost as bad it's people who
are
in denial about this being donald
trump's party it's clueless people it's
people who were willing to go with
whatever trump wanted for as long as it
was sort of beneficial to them and gave
them access to centers of power or
whatever the case may be
he's marginally less crazy i guess
because he's willing to say this so for
all we know they're bailing on trump
because they plan to build consensus
around
republicans nominating some kind of
centrist
in 2024 instead of someone like a trump
or a desantis but these are not good
people and william barr deserves barely
any praise william barr has done one
percent of of all that william barr has
done
um since working for trump as attorney
general one percent of what he said and
done makes sense and seems sort of like
morally grounded and so he can get that
one percent praise from us good thing
he's saying this he's saying it now to
sell books and i wouldn't trust this guy
as far as i can throw him
um i want to talk about
a really serious issue
which is that we now know we know that
there are people on the political right
willing to do violence merely over
political disagreements
and that's why i was particularly
worried
when i saw a headline indicating
that the nevada governor a democrat
steve sisilak
was confronted and had his life
threatened at a restaurant over the
weekend and um this is i mean listen uh
part of the content here is the fact
that sizzolak is out at a restaurant
without security
and it's sad that he probably needs
security all the time
but it is what it is and i'm going to
play the video for you in a moment um
two men accosted and berated steve
sisilak and his wife kathy hurling
racist language and threats as they
followed him out of a restaurant into a
parking lot
this is really ugly video nevada
governor sizolak and his wife kathy were
involved in a harrowing encounter two
men screamed racist and violent threats
in a statement shared to twitter the
communications director explained it
happened sunday when he was walking
through a restaurant to have dinner the
governor was approached by a customer in
the establishment who has to take a
photo
uh it then became clear that the guy was
just uh kidding around about wanting to
take a photo and started berating him
and saying are you in here without
security
following him another guy started
yelling swearing of course there was
covet disinformation riddled within the
riddling the the harassment about
hydroxychloroquine etc when they started
to leave
um
uh sizzulak's wife is asian and one of
the guys started um yelling china piece
of s
we should string you up by lamp posts
etc
let's take a look at the video
this is uh this is pretty horrifying
stuff syslag right
it's amazing i can't tell you what a
piece of you are sorry to hear that new
world order trader piece of bastard
so
new world order conspiracy number one
here without security
out here without a cop out here without
security now one of the other things is
many of you are probably saying i had no
idea sizzulak was the governor of nevada
like he's not even a controversial guy
he he's a completely just basic
democratic governor he's not
particularly progressive or anything and
and so it's not even really about any
particular policy
you got balls on you boy i'm not moving
wait till we find all the money that
pulled his way through oh man yeah
hiding the hydroxyl oh you in trouble
money that flowed his way
for hiding the hydroxychloroquine
these are sick people guys you can't you
can't go hey you know what let's talk
about our political differences again to
use this sort of banal example it's not
hey you know what you want a 42 top tax
rate i want a 20 flat tax
let's talk about the origins of our
disagreements now
this is not that this is you've hidden
the money for you you've you've received
money for hiding hydroxychloroquine you
can't talk sense to these people they're
beyond reach
yeah you better get the [ __ ] out of here
i didn't go somewhere else where's your
security at huh huh
where's your don't touch me lady where's
your security at huh do you want to sell
us all down the river
you working
working for china so third conspiracy
so we've got new world order
uh receiving money and slash for hiding
hydroxychloroquine working for china
we should string you up by land post
right now [ __ ] boy and there's the
death threat string you up by a lamp
post sort of an uh alluding alluding
quite frankly to a lynching you know
what they do to traders
that's right i think it's awesome you
you're running into a patriot now huh
huh where's your security at i heard
about you banging that little girl and
wrecking your car does she know about
that huh steve
mr [ __ ] lack
you craziness china working [ __ ]
[ __ ]
where's your security at [ __ ]
you lucky i'm a law abiding citizen
because your daughter's with you i'm
going to leave you alone now
respectful guy huh
your daughter's with you so now i'm
going to leave you alone
patrick
is considered patriotic in some parts of
the country
yeah baby
[Laughter]
so a lot of people like that i mean
that's considered um that now these are
the same people who if someone just
shows up with a sign outside mitch
mcconnell's house they'd go whoa these
these are private people
and they're being bothered
and that's really bad the tone is bad
and you shouldn't be allowed no and
look at what is going these are truly
dangerous people and you know i i know
enough people both in media and in
politics to know that
they you know you're supposed to like
not you're not really supposed to admit
that you're scared by that
but i've spoken to people in media and
politics who go this happened to me and
i was scared by it i really was because
these people are crazy particularly in
states where
everybody's got guns you know or at
least a lot of people do
this is genuinely horrifying stuff and
um i know that some of you are going to
write to me and say that was actually a
right-wing podcaster the guy who did it
i don't even care i don't i don't know
the guy's name i don't whether he's a
podcast or not i'm not going to i'm not
even gonna give any i'm gonna mention
the fact that that guy might have some
kind of show or anything like that this
is really really disgusting stuff it's
dangerous stuff
and i fear and i mean listen it's not
it's a i fear it's happened before
that violence is done against people
uh you can go back to the 80s gabby
giffords etcetera there's so many of
these examples um and the these people
are dangerous we can't for a second be
allowed to think it's just rhetoric
they're just expressing differences of
opinion differences of opinion hiding
money uh taking money for hiding
hydroxychloroquine
you're working for china i mean come on
guys very very dangerous stuff and i
don't know
how we root that out i really don't that
that's not a person you can sit down
with and have a rational conversation
with so i'm open to ideas from you guys
how do we fix this stuff i don't know
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show okay we have really substantive
follow-up to a major story from either
last week or the week before not too
long ago you might remember that i
reported to you that two prosecutors
working on the manhattan district
attorney's criminal probe of donald
trump's organization resign they just
they said we quit we're not doing it
anymore and we went that story this was
from okay february 23rd so two weeks ago
and in this original reporting two
prosecutors resigned
um this was a years old probe
we didn't know why
we as far as was announced the
investigation was still ongoing and it
was sort of a real question mark and at
the time my speculation remember
speculation was
these prosecutors realized
they're not going to indict trump
they're not going to charge trump and
they felt my work is being done in vain
i'm getting the hell out of here that
was my speculation and i identified it
as such to be clear the speculation on
the right was
they quit
because they knew there was no evidence
against the trump organization and they
felt they were being railroaded into
there was no evidence of that
there was no evidence of my hypothesis
but i argued to you
that my hypothesis is far more plausible
and my hypothesis has now been
vindicated and vindicated exactly
prosecutors resigned says a new article
after new york d.a said
he wasn't prepared to move forward with
the indictment of donald trump
we now know the reason and
i got lucky it happened to be the reason
i said
two top prosecutors leading the criminal
probe into trump and his business
resigned after the manhattan district
attorney said he was not prepared to
authorize an indictment against the
former president a person familiar with
the investigation said
and there it is
carrie dunn and mark pomerant two senior
prosecutors on the team resigned last
month one day after manhattan district
attorney alvin bragg informed them
he's not prepared to move forward with
criminal charges the resignations
followed weeks of internal debate and
discussion over the strength of evidence
and whether it could pass the hurdle of
proving a crime now i want to be really
clear
it's possible
that the d.a is correct we don't have
enough to prove a trump crime here that
may well be but the question was why
would they resign would they resign
because there's nothing here to
investigate doesn't seem likely because
they've been investigating for a long
time if that was the reason they would
have known there was no evidence a long
time ago
or is it more likely that they were
getting frustrated with the fact that
they've been investigating for so long
they have what they might see as a solid
case built up
and yet no one is willing to indict
and that appears to be it now
interestingly uh there's some detail
here about why this is
um the abrupt resignation okay where's
the section here
uh it was originally started by psy
vance we know that the new york times
first reported that the resignations
followed a decision by bragg to stop
presenting evidence to the grand jury
the strength of the evidence against
trump has been debated by attorneys in
the office for months some prosecutors
including the two that resigned believe
there was sufficient evidence to charge
trump while others including career
prosecutors were skeptical they could
get a conviction because of the
difficulty improving criminal intent
that's another thing we've talked about
a lot of the crimes here that donald
trump could be charged with
really require you to show what his
state of mind and intent was
and that can be very very difficult on
the one hand some prosecutors believe
trump speaks with a lot of hyperbole but
it wasn't clear that they could show he
acted with intent to defraud
there's also a very important piece here
about michael cohen
and this i think we should talk about a
little more multiple factors were at
play including lack of key trump
organization insider cooperating
with insiders cooperating with the
investigation who at trial could walk
the jury through the evidence the
possible value of using michael cohen
trump's former personal attorney who in
testimony before congress alleged trump
inflated and devalued assets for his
advantage
was discussed with the team
cohen pleaded guilty to nine charges
including lying to congress he was once
close to trump but his conviction and
public statements critical of trump
would give the defense ammunition to aim
to discredit him that is a very very
interesting piece of this
the idea is
if you you don't have a cooperating
witness from inside trump's business you
do have all sorts of claims from michael
cohen but michael cohen if you read
between the lines what they're saying is
would be easy to discredit
and destroy his credibility in a
cross-examination on the basis that he
has perjured himself
he has uh lied he has a long history
of all of the trouble that ultimately
got him convicted
the counter to that be well those are
all crimes he committed
for donald trump but i think it's a very
legitimate question to say
what is a jury going to think
if michael cohen is their main witness
and is cross-examined about all the
times that he lied well so you told the
lie then how are we to believe that you
are telling the truth now etcetera
etcetera so the point here is
this is number one exactly what we
believe was going on prosecutors getting
sick of the fact that they're doing
their work
and nobody really seems willing to
prosecute that seems to be going on and
then number two this is why i continue
to say donald trump is not going to
spend a single day in prison and i
apologize to people who think i'm
causing that to be the truth no
prosecutors are listening to me they're
going to decide what to do regardless of
what i say i see it as a very high bar
to reach that a prosecutor will say i'm
going to be the first
the first to indict
a former president
uh i think if one did it others would
fall
but who is willing to be first we
haven't found anybody quite yet and
that's the latest with the prosecution
that's in manhattan there's georgia
southern district of new york there's
all all these other things going on but
at least as far as what's going on in
manhattan a logical follow-up to the
story from uh february here's a little
interesting video this uh the video i'm
about to play for you is of radical
republican congressman matt gates
and he was
very
mildly confronted about the fact that he
continues to insist that trump won on
local tv
and this is being reported uh sort of
all over the place
as matt gates gets humiliating reality
check to his face on live local tv or
on alternate matt gates slapped with
epic reality check after echoing trump's
voter fraud claims
it's not really what happened now i
appreciate i appreciate that gates was
pushed you know challenged at all on his
lies about 2020. but basically what
happens here is gate says i believe
trump won and the interviewer goes yeah
but that would require like a lot of
conspiracy you know a lot of people
acting together
and then gates just spews a ton of
nonsense so it's not it's not a major
reality check let's take a look at it so
you're still maintaining 2020 election
was stolen is are we still going with
that listen i believe that donald trump
won the 2020 election i believe that he
won the election
you can't say that without saying that
there was a gigantic conspiracy across
this country and supervisor of elections
offices everywhere right to make this
happen and we haven't still seen any
evidence that proves that yeah because
so many of the courts that should have
taken those matters up rejected
evidentiary hearings on jurisdiction
grounds i mean i know the affidavits
that came out of michigan regarding the
tcf center in detroit now remember this
brings us back to
affidavits are not evidence and yes
affidavits affidavits can can be
introduced and examined but affidavits
are not actually evidence and this is
just another one of the lines that they
keep repeating it's almost taking me
back to december of 2020. but we have
affidavit affidavits are not strictly
speaking evidence established a factual
basis to be able to go and have
evidentiary hearings but too often i
think uh judges just didn't have the
courage to take it up courage it's most
unfortunate but i'm still engaged in the
fight and election integrity going
forward oh yeah because florida used to
be the laughing stock of elections and
governor desantis fired the elections
officials who didn't run clean elections
and now lo and behold florida's a model
for the country so i want to bring
florida's message and our story can you
imagine florida as a model for the
country um so listen i mean like it's
great that he was asked uh where's your
evidence for that
but at the same time that was not
exactly
a brutal reality check that it's made
out to be now notice the language matt
gates uses he says i believe donald
trump won they are the ones who always
say
facts don't care about your feelings and
yet he believes trump won absent any
actual facts that would point that way
um
one other thing
there is this whole so matt gates has a
lot going on
one of the things is he's being
investigated for the potential child sex
trafficking and all of that he's hired a
child you know a sex crime defense
attorney and all these different things
on the other hand he's also paddling
around with marjorie taylor green and
telling lies about the election the
third thing is there's still this very
strange story about how he says his dad
was extorted by someone or there was an
attempt to extort he's also asked about
that during this interview
any updates on the department of justice
investigation
the one big update is that since we
talked last the individual who had been
indicted for trying to extort me pled
guilty to extorting me and my family and
uh i hope that that would work the wire
fraud yes and i hope that that
investigation is ongoing because other
people literally went on national
television and said they were working
with steve alford in this deal those
people should be the next to be indicted
okay so he hopes but i guess but i guess
doesn't know
if the investigation is still going on
uh it would be really great for one of
these cartoonish trumpian right wingers
to have a really big
fall from grace and we've talked before
about
fishy stuff with marjorie taylor green
and taking two homestead exemptions
which you can only take one and i'm not
gonna go back through what a homestead
declaration of homestead is and and all
that but you're only allowed to have one
that was being investigated
you know did it fall into some kind of
investigative black hole we don't know
um lauren bobert a whole bunch of
different campaign funds related things
will anything ever come of it we don't
know
uh madison cawthorne whole other thing
you know the russian honeypot i mean we
can't even get into that right now
matt gates
the one facing the most serious criminal
charges potentially it would be a really
interesting thing to see
if one of these you know the major
cartoonist trump is the younger
cartoonish trumpists are are people like
these not cartoonists this guy's no
these guys know bill waterson that's for
sure but the the most cartoonish uh
trumpist are bobert
uh gates green and cothorn at this point
sort of if one of them had a real big
fall from grace particularly if they um
had criminal charges against them or
some other major scandal it would be
interesting to see how trump would react
in general to that group probably
initially saying they're being
railroaded but
over the long term maybe he would sort
of step back from supporting that group
unclear we will see we will follow it
but hey at least they asked matt gates
to try to defend the claim that trump
won in november he didn't do a great job
but he tried
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p here's an interesting
observation from one of our viewers
about what they see
as a decline in obvious online trolls
coinciding with russian sanctions take a
listen
hi david
is it me or have you also noticed a lot
less if not almost a complete halt of
these
so-called all-american or right-wing
trolls that used to plague social media
and to be honest the internet in general
well everywhere i've been going whether
it's reddit facebook or youtube etc etc
i'm noticing less and less of these
online trolls
suspiciously it seems to me that they
correlate with the sanctions against
russia
do you think this could be a coincidence
do you think these are paid actors we
know for a fact that a lot of these are
paid actors
i just thought
i'd like to know your take on that and
if you've noticed that or some of your
viewers have noticed that as well so
interestingly enough i have noticed that
how can i even explain this when when
you do what i do you start to get a
sense when you take a 30 000 foot view
of the replies that i get on twitter
and the youtube comments and the reddit
posts you start to get a very top-level
view of sort of like what's the theme
and it is very much true
that what was previously overwhelmingly
this kind of like
nationalistic pro-american
anti-communist
sort of propaganda that sometimes is
associated with russian troll farms like
the internet research agency and others
that stuff does seem to have declined a
little bit
and instead what we're seeing is very
similar type of activity like brand new
accounts
that only post to our subreddit or brand
new accounts
that are leaving
almost identical different accounts
leaving almost identical pro putin
messages on our youtube channel there
seems to have been a shift from some of
that hard right all-american nationalist
trolling
to kind of like pro-putin pro-russia
trolling that spreads disinformation
about ukraine and insists ukraine is
filled with nazis and kind of furthering
that stuff i i would be lying if i said
i didn't notice it that being said i
want to be really careful because there
also could be sort of like an
availability bias of sorts where
we're covering russia ukraine more
so it may just be that i'm looking at
more comments related to that part of
the world and so i'm noticing them more
but i would be lying if i said i didn't
notice the exact same thing the caller
is saying so if there were if there were
truth to it if we could empirically show
the american nationalist trolling is
down and the pro-putin trolling is up
it's theoretically possible that this is
just a shift in the priorities of these
russian troll farms which are very
sophisticated quite frankly
and they're just kind of shifting their
message that's totally plausible it also
could be that all of us are just paying
attention more to russia and ukraine and
so if you're watching 10 russia ukraine
videos a week instead of none and then
you look at the comments you're going to
notice a lot more pro putin propaganda
naturally than the hard right american
stuff because that's just the subject
matter of the videos you're looking at
so
i i think what the caller is saying is
interesting
we'd have to study it and study it
empirically
and that's not something that i've done
but i'm curious to hear whether people
in the audience are seeing the same
thing
on today's bonus show calls for the
united states to ban russian oil are
getting momentum gaining momentum
despite concerns about it accelerating
inflation even more
we will also talk as we have spoken
before about the reality that not every
military conflict or invasion or war
gets the same media coverage we'll talk
about why and we'll talk about the
consequences of that and lastly high
schools could lose ap classes advanced
placement classes
if they ban so-called required topics
from being taught
and we're going to talk about what those
topics are and much more i will
reminisce about my ap econ class that i
took in high school which first got me
interested in economics and led to me
doing economics at the undergraduate and
graduate level in college
ap really had a big impact on me and
losing those classes would be uh a very
very bad thing
you can get access to the bonus show
instantly by signing up at
[Music]
joinpacman.com i will see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
cheese butter is the delicious gourmet
cheese melt that blends four indulgent
cheeses and seasoned butter i love this
stuff perfect on bread bagel sandwiches
veggies and more you'll get 15 off at
cheesebutter.com
pacman the link is down below